thank you for joining us more than 60
people have died in a fire in the South
African city of Johannesburg the fire
gathered an abandoned building
Sheltering mostly homeless people
recovery operations are underway as
emergency crews look for more bodies the
death toll is expected to rise it's
unclear what caused the blaze that began
in the early hours of Thursday morning
and this happened in central
johannesburg's Marshall Town the area
was once a business district of South
Africa's economic Hub the fire engulfed
this five-story building
who's at the scene in Johannesburg
Forest so the death toll family has been
rising what's the latest
volley that death toll has risen quite
sharply in just a matter of hours when
the story first broke earlier this
morning Emergency Services had said that
they'd found 10 people did following
that place they extinguished the fire
within a couple of hours and immediately
began a search and Recovery operations
once that fire was out and by now
they've said that at least 64 people
have been found dead and it's likely
that number will rise because there were
just so many people living in the
building behind us we can still see a
little bit of smoke coming out of that
building but what's happened is that in
the last couple of years it's been an
abandoned building here in as you
mentioned what was the central business
district this this was a commercial hub
in Johannesburg but once businesses
moved out of the area buildings like
this were taken over by informal
landlords once they they were abandoned
by the original owners and that's when
people moved in yeah I was going to ask
you about that in fact these buildings
are described as hijacked buildings and
I understand there are quite a few of
them in South Africa what is safety like
and what are the conditions like in
these buildings
well it's exactly that issue around
safety that has led to this incident
there really are very few safety
measures in place we understand from
Emergency Services because the building
was abandoned there isn't running water
there wasn't running water and if there
was an electricity connection it would
have been deemed illegal illegal
connections to ensure that there's
electricity in the building so not
sanctioned by the city not regulated
essentially people doing whatever they
could to live in the building as
adequately as they could and so yes
safety was definitely a massive issue
for people uh in a building like this
and of course there are dozens of
buildings like this across the city and
across major cities in Johannesburg I
want to bring in the mother of a lady
who was living in the building we're
speaking to treasury shipping she is the
mother of a woman who was living here
for at least a year and treasury you are
waiting for any word about where she
might be you've been here for hours I
can only imagine what you're going
through especially with the limited
information available
years I've been here since morning
before seven and we still haven't gotten
any update as to what is happening we've
just been told that people have been
evacuated bodies are soaking recovered
is the Delta Rising so yeah it's the
suspense that is actually killing us
because we don't know what is actually
happening I don't know if my daughter is
alive or I can only hope for her to be
alive but we don't we don't know what do
you do at this point given there's been
so little information you don't know
whether you should stay here or go to
hospitals what is your family doing
trying to find information the problem
is we can't move
before we were told to reach hospitals
were they taken to because we also don't
have an idea and the other thing is we
are told to wait until they can tell us
exactly where to go where the people has
been taken to so we we don't know we are
all stuck here waiting to get a
direction as to what needs to be done
treasury I just want to ask you do you
have any idea why your daughter would
have been in this building given the
safety concerns and given that emergency
services have said there's a very
informal setting within that building
and it's just so dangerous
um yeah from a parent to say that it's
very sad because my daughter was on
drugs
um she ended up leaving home and coming
to stay in a place where she can easily
access
um the substances so yeah that's the
reason why she she easier drugs behind
everything
especially we appreciate your time and
we wish you the best in finding your
daughter it's there are a number of
people here just like treasury waiting
for any word around what's happened in
that building how far the recovery
operation is we do know from emergency
services that at least 43 other people
have been taken to hospital many with
smoke inhalation and other injuries but
so far volley 64 people have been found
dead and those operations are continuing
just behind us such a tragic situation
in so many sad stories for me the Miller
lifers in Johannesburg thank you very
much